now then to the United States and
Hillary Clinton got that right one a
resounding victory in last night's South
Carolina primary it's a win that looks
set to add momentum to campaign for the
Democratic nomination out of Super
Tuesday this week and I spoke to her
former innovations advisor Alec Ross
he's the author of a new book the
industries of the future about how
technology will change the world we live
in I started by asking him what those
industries will be well they're going to
be a handful of things that shape the
world over the next 10 years as much as
the Internet is shaped the world over
the last 20 from artificial intelligence
and robotics to the commercialization of
genomics to big data I think we're at an
inflection point where there where
change is going to happen at us very
very fast ok and how is it going to
happen is it all going to happen more
and more through the innovator the
entrepreneur individuals and groups or
does the state have a role to play as
well I think the state has a role but
it's a much diminished role relative to
what it was in the Industrial Age or in
the agricultural age I think that
innovation and economic change is
evermore propelled by entrepreneurs it's
by people in basements who come up with
great ideas that they turn into products
that they get investment that they
unleash into the world and and it's in
the global terms me the big thought here
you know we see that most I think nearly
all of the global tech companies are
from the United States are we going to
see that change I'm going to see it
spread around the globe could we see a
an African Google or Apple or something
like that
absolutely so one of the theses of my
book the industries of the future is the
last 20 years were great for this little
narrow piece of California called
Silicon Valley but I do believe that
over the next ten years there will be 10
or 12 places around the world London by
the way which I think could very well be
one of them and they may not equal
Silicon Valley but I think very big
businesses are going to be created by
the 20-somethings in the 30-somethings
in a dozen places around the world that
aren't America but what is I mean is
there something we can learn that the
rest of the world can learn from Silicon
Valley in particular is there a formula
that they've got right that others
so far and not doing well there there
are things that can be done first of all
you have to create the conditions that
lend themselves to very early-stage
high-risk investment so you can't be
risk-averse at all and I think the
people are beginning to pick up all this
secondly I think there's a cultural bit
to it I'm 44 years old and when I'm in
government ranks I'm typically among the
youngest people among the youngest at
the table but when I'm in Silicon Valley
among I'm among the oldest and so I
think culturally recognizing that
somebody in their 20s or 30s ought to be
invested in is important as well and
then lastly I think you need a spirit of
audacity and you know you can't just
innovate incrementally you have to have
a big idea everybody tells you you're
gonna fail and you go right at it and I
think more people are picking up on that
tell me about some of the concerns you
touched on earlier there in particular
artificial intelligence and robotics I
mean I don't know if this is a silly
question or not but if some of the
people you've been sitting in rooms with
are sitting in rooms in 10 20 30 40 50
years hence might they be sitting with
entities other than humans I mean how
far can it go that's not a silly
question at all to me I think the robots
of the cartoons and movies from the
1970s are going to be the reality of the
2020s and I'll spare you all the details
why but the rise of artificial
intelligence is going to take robots
from doing work that we just think of as
manual the work of men with big strong
shoulders and ports factories and mills
and it will increasingly do work that is
cognitive do the work of men and women
with white collars and so this is going
to change labor and this is why the
industries of the future is not utopian
and it's not dystopian it isn't you know
I don't write to say oh everything's
going to be great we're going to live
lives of abundance but nor do I write it
from the fetal position and sort of
fists clenched you know railing against
the future it's gonna be tricky let me
ask you more about the state versus the
corporation's and some people see them
as being in cahoots but we see right now
in the United States one of the big
battles I think which will define a lot
of issues for the future I'm talking
about
Paul versus the FBI over one phone and
creating the technology to unlock it
that's right so 80% of the time I will
side with law enforcement and the
intelligence services I worked in
government I understand that perspective
in this case though I think the FBI is
making a mistake and the reason why I
think the FBI is making a mistake is
it's not really about one phone what
they want Apple to do is redevelop their
iOS software and make it easier to walk
into a back door the problem with that
is that if you are creating a back door
for GCHQ or for the FBI the Chinese can
walk through it
the Russians can walk through it and so
I do think that as our networks become
more security sensitive we actually need
more encryption you of course right for
Hillary Clinton when she was Secretary
of State and was it and still is a large
question marks about why she seemed to
communicate through email on her
personal account tens of thousands of
emails some of which have been released
do you know she said she made a mistake
but you know why she did it you know I I
haven't asked her why she did it I have
a feeling she probably wasn't paying
that much attention to her own email I
mean she's 67 years old she's not a geek
by Nature
I have a feeling that you know somebody
else said oh we're gonna do this we
think it's in your best interest and she
probably nodded and said okay and now
has to live with the implications of
that choice and you think it's going to
be an issue in the election campaign
particularly if it is Donald Trump
against Hillary Clinton well if it's
Donald Trump versus Hillary Clinton I
hope to God Almighty that's something
more than emails are determining the
election do you think it will be Donald
Trump I mean looking as a Democrat on
the Republican side it looks like it I
mean it looks like Donald Trump has
tapped into the anxiety that lots of
people in the United States feel he's
figured out how to take that anxiety and
turn it into anger and is directing that
anger he's saying hey it's the
establishments fault it's brown people's
fault it's people of low incomes who are
now in our national health service who
you have to pay for
I think he's demented I think he's
vulgar I think he's a horrible
human being but he's also a
communications genius pulling your
punches there what about on the Democrat
side Bernie Sanders that would make it
very very strange for the United States
wouldn't it be having someone so far to
the right and someone so far to the left
sash a socialist versus a fascist who
would have ever guessed I do think that
Hillary Clinton is well-positioned to
beat Bernie Sanders I do think though
that here too as with Donald Trump I
think that Bernie Sanders has tapped
into something I think he also has
identified the anxiety of people
particularly young people in his case
people who are in their 20s who've got
loads of university debt who have a hard
time making it into the world work world
and he sort of laid out a vision for
them and so I think it's it's it's a bit
tricky for some people who are more
centrist and more pragmatic like Hillary
to make their way through this very loud
political environment and lastly mr.
also give us your thoughts I mean it's
back to what we were talking about
earlier and the industries of the future
and the needs for open welcoming
economies as opposed free movements of
people as well and I don't want to
relate it to the debate that's been had
in the UK right now about membership of
the European Union to remain or to leave
what are your thoughts on which way the
UK should go well I'll be honest I think
that as an American what I think is less
important than what any any citizen of
the United Kingdom thinks what I having
said that I do think that in a world
that is growing more connected the idea
that Great Britain would disconnect
itself a little bit more I think would
make it more difficult economically I
mean it's hard to posit that London or
Cambridge or other centers of innovation
are going to be home to people from all
over the world starting businesses if
suddenly it's really an island unto
itself and not part of a larger whole
well we're all standing there this was
great seeing you all across best of luck
got with the book the industries of the
future thank you for having me